have you ever been fired off a job no
wow i have not while i was shooting i
think i've lost
parts that they had like given me and
then i like they
took them away that's happened for sure
though oh god
you said in an interview that sometimes
you feel like you've forgotten it all
when you get on set
like you question everything and then it
takes you like a day or two
how does that work after all these
movies you just feel like sometimes you
go back on set and you're like
do i know how to do this explain that
yeah it's weird it's almost like an
irrational
fear or something that
basically before almost every single job
i do if there's like more than a week
between a job or something
there's a point where i'm like man i
don't know if i can do this
i don't it's and it's like there's a
part of me i'm like well
you've been through this before and you
do know how to do this and you'll get on
set and you'll do it and that's like
your thing and but like
the belief that i can't do it
is is like real i mean it's like there
do you feel
nerves is it nerves do you feel these
like intense like
anxiety or what is that super intense
anxiety
and also like more than just a feeling
like the actual
like the thinking of like i i don't
think i can do it like i don't i don't
really think
i'm up to this it's a weird thing and
you know how crazy it is right you know
how
you're logically you're a smart guy so
you're thinking i've done this i've
killed it i know what i'm doing so why
am i feeling like this
i know it's the weirdest thing i don't
know i've i
i've talked to a couple actors that kind
of they're like
yeah you have that too you know it's
kind of a weird thing
i don't know it's probably just sort of
nerves or just sitting around with too
much to
to think about um i don't know though
i almost wonder if like when you stop
feeling if i were to stop feeling that
way i almost wonder if
like something would get stale or if i
wouldn't be as excited or
you know because you only get that way
if you care like if you don't care at
all
you're not going to be like i don't know
if i can do this you're going to be like
i don't care if i can do this
you know what i mean